I'm sitting at the airport and they have
all this NFL pregame going on and I'm
thinking I [ __ ] I'm gonna miss
everything and I'm watching the pregame
and which I never watch and I haven't
really watched it in years it's why I
don't know anybody's names anymore and
I'm really bad at I mean part of its
because I'm on the road all the [ __ ]
time but I think I don't know
sorry guys can you tell him looking at
something else here on the computer I'm
sitting there watching it and the first
thing I see and I started tweeting this
[ __ ] and it kind of started I got a
little thing going on Twitter I'm just
the dumb [ __ ] that they say and the
whole [ __ ] in the NFL pregame tape right
there okay you see right there was
making decision he is making decisions
and that is a good thing he's looking at
it not only last year he was just
looking it was his first read he was
telegraphing where he was gonna throw
the ball if you see right here what he's
doing he is now checking down the field
at second in third reads now I can tell
you when a quarterback does that that is
when he's starting to play the
quarterback position in an NFL level
right [ __ ] all of that [ __ ] just a
bunch of [ __ ] people in suit breaking
down the game the way it never needed to
be broken down it is completely a
product of [ __ ] 9000 24-hour sports
channels I mean dude I'm sitting there
it's like two and a half hours before
kickoff and they're already doing
pregame it's like dude pregame used to
be a half hour before brent musburger
Irv cross that Kennedy woman whatever
the hell jack II can't not Jackie
Kennedy what the hell was her name and
then Jimmy the Greek that was CBS and
that NBC you had [ __ ] Brian Gumbel
and Mike Adamle NFL 81 right that's what
the [ __ ] do you that's all you just
watched that and they went around the
league and it was cool bing-bang-boom
and you were done and then you went to
your local feed now
just cut these guys are out there
they're acting it out on that half a
football field over and if I tell you
right now what they're trying to do is
they're trying to turn around the
culture in the locker you own the locker
room for years it is it has been a
mentality that we are not gonna win the
big one and that's why they brought in
Joe [ __ ] bag of doughnuts to come and
then they drive around but no stupidest
[ __ ] ever over and [ __ ] over and over
so anyway so I go again on I started
tweeting all of that [ __ ] and you know
just making up player names and all the
dumb [ __ ] that they say oh yeah he's a
changed man he came in this came into
camp in the best shape of his football
life he's listening to his coaches he
has it his wife and he only tested
positive to weed and I'll tell you that
type of attitude that type of attitude
is yeah it's contagious in the locker
room how many [ __ ] times did they
even sit there rolling their eyes with
if their football speak drives me up the
[ __ ] wall
Oh anyway he needs to do is he needs to
feel the pass rush you have in the
National Football League which you have
to be able to do is feel when that
pocket it is collapsing around you you
gotta have a clock in your head you
gotta have a clock in your head and you
want once it's clicking down you have to
know you must get rid of the football
cuz I'll tell you right now if you don't
do that you take a sack right there that
is a drive killer Mike absolutely agree
what he's doing there did you tell he's
patting the ball he's telegraphing his
passes this is the type of stuff that
they worked on in the offseason he
showed some promising moments in the
preseason but I gotta tell you today I
don't know where that was and I got a
one peel I've got wonder was it time you
hit the panic button down to Tampa who
the [ __ ] can sit there and watch that
horse and then what I love is sports
fans watch that [ __ ] and then it gets
it's like a virus and then it gets in
their [ __ ] heads and then they go out
to sports bars and you talk about
football and then they start sounding
like those people
okay you know don't you gotta have a
[ __ ] clock in your head kid you know
one one thousand two one thousand
[ __ ] get rid of it throw it out of
bounds
dude you're allowed to do that as long
as you're within the confines of the
[ __ ] pocket dude I can't I can't
[ __ ] I can't go to sports bars why
would you I don't give a [ __ ] how
[ __ ] broke you are there is no reason
to not have the NFL package there isn't
all right you can go 40 [ __ ] days
without food as long as you got water
you're fine
do yourself a [ __ ] favor starve
yourself and yes
okay I'm advocating anorexia to get the
NFL package to not go down to the
[ __ ] sports bar eating that
heart-attack food watching a bunch of
grown men walking around in jerseys like
they're dating dating the [ __ ] player
Dan horseshit you're gonna go down there
looking at those tired waitresses trying
to [ __ ] it up and they're [ __ ] cut
off red shirt listening to that [ __ ]
unbelievers it time to make a change
I'll tell you I mean if I am if I am the
offensive coordinator he's had you got
to understand with this kid this kid has
had 19 offensive coordinators in the
last seven seasons okay I still don't
think that we have seen what this kid is
able to do out there I'm still holding
on but you have to understand that he
has head ain't seen hints I don't know I
can't [ __ ] read I'm annoying myself
just just even listening to this [ __ ]
and I'll tell you get all these teams
they know each other they meet twice a
year these teams they know what they do
and I'll tell you right now it's hard to
be team three times one season I'll tell
you right now if I'm a football fan I
got to be looking to that first matchup
of these Seattle Seahawks against those
San Francisco 49ers
can the 49ers get over the hump I mean
this is the question I mean there's
rumors that Jim Harbaugh is losing the
locker room how can you sit and watch
that is anyways I'll tell you anyway I
can tell oh you know I'll give you my
predictions for week to week to pregame
football analysis and now off to New
England where shockingly last week they
lost decisively to these Miami Dolphins
of the dolphin Miami County Dayne Wade
[ __ ] area come I'll tell you right
now me what do you thinks gonna happen
when they come in and they play the the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] Austin City isotopes
what do you think's gonna happen right
now you know I mean I mean look we all
know what Tom Brady can do we all know
Bill Belichick is the genius but I'll
tell you right now I mean I mean we do
Talent or no Channel and I'm een you'll
be you got to be concerned about that
second half of me there lights out that
it's gonna be a lot of that [ __ ] I mean
if they lose today they they're over to
for the first time in the Brady sugar
they like you gonna be doing that for a
[ __ ] hour not for an hour they'll do
it for a little bit and then they're
gonna I don't know what the [ __ ] else
they're gonna talk about I see the world
through my team and I know that they're
gonna be doing that [ __ ] or you can just
skip all of that you can go [ __ ] work
out at the gym right go for a hike with
your [ __ ] dog or some [ __ ] and you
can come back the wonderful world of
[ __ ] DVI you can come back an hour
before the game after the game started
you can just plow through all the
[ __ ] halftime everything and just get
right to the third quarter right let
your wife watch The Real Housewives
during the first half you know and you
just make before you go out to the gym
you just say listen sweetheart you grab
a buy a handful of hair the back of our
head you feel assured if you [ __ ]
shut off the recording I swear to god
I'm gonna have you live under the coffee
table with nothing talking joking
blogger world